la parole est maintenant notre collègue
caroline cayeux pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre nous avons atteint ce mois-ci
monsieur le premier ministre le chiffre
ahurissant de 5,7 millions de demandeurs
d'emploi dont 42 milles supplémentaires
pour le seul mois de novembre le chômage
continue son inexorable progression pour
atteindre un taux inégalé à ce jour en
france
nous sommes le seul pays d'europe à
n'avoir pas créé d'emplois au cours des
14 derniers mois
monsieur le premier ministre c'est
clairement votre politique qui est mis
en cause
alors pourquoi la france est-elle
aujourd'hui le plus mauvais élève de la
communauté européenne
allez vous enfin sortir de vos positions
dogmatiques qui nous éloigne tous les
jours un peu plus du retour à la
croissance pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la ministre du
travail de l'emploi la formation
professionnelle et du dialogue social
merci messieurs dans mes dames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice caroline cayeux dans
quelle situation sommes nous il est faux
de dire qu'il n'ya pas eu de créations
nettes
après plusieurs années de destruction
nette d'emplois depuis un an il y à 40
mille créations nettes d'emplois cette
reprise économique
cette reprise de l'activité économique
même timide mam graduelle et bien là
quelle est la situation
nous avons certains secteurs où il
continue on continue à avoir des
destructions nettes d'emplois ces
secteurs c'est l'industrie c'est le
bâtiment le prêt à taux zéro que nous
développons à partir du 1er janvier 2016
son élargissement permettra justement de
relancer le bâtiment
quelle est la situation en matière de
service cela repart est-ce que c'est
suffisant est-ce que vous pensez que
j'attends dans mon bureau que la
croissance soit 1,5 pour cent
tranquillement non nous travaillons que
nous mettons en place justement un
allègement pour les particuliers
employeurs
cela vise justement à permettre ce
gisement d'emplois ses créations
concrètement nous le disons je les dis à
l'instant il faut que nous continuions à
aller plus vite et plus fort et toutes
les pistes sont sur la table
la réécriture du code du travail par la
négociation collective
nous y travaillons l'apprentissage tout
est sur la table plusieurs présidents de
région sont prêts à travailler avec nous
venez je suis particulièrement ouverte
pour améliorer les choses mais sachez
sur l'apprentissage
il faut bien sûr un front de tous les
décideurs publics mais je crois aussi
que nous pouvons aussi nous avons lever
les freins financiers
nous avons relevé les neuf les frais non
financiers nous travaillons avec la
ministre de l'éducation nationale sur la
question de l'orientation scolaire
mais permettez moi de vous dire que dans
le cadre du pacte de responsabilité dans
le cadre du pacte de responsabilité
il ya eu des engagements que certaines
branches professionnelles en matière
d'emprunt tissage en matière de création
d'emplois il faut également qu'ils
tiennent leurs engagements bien madame
caroline cayeux pour lui dit madame la
ministre
j'entends bien vous annoncer un plan
massif de formation pour les chômeurs
vous annoncer que l'on va mettre le
paquet sur l'apprentissage
mais comment voulez vous que l'on vous
croit alors que l'une des premières
décisions de françois hollande fut de
baisser puis de baisser les crédits
alloués à l'embauché des apprentis
les résultats sont là 297 mille contrats
d'apprentissage en 2012 265000 en 2014
vous avez parlé de baisser le coût du
travail mais vous avez multiplié les
charges qui asphyxie les entreprises et
vous avez matraquer
les employeurs en réalité en réalité
vous jouer les pompiers pyromanes
vous allumez le feu et devant la colère
des français vous essayé de l'éteindre
l'emploi devait être la priorité du
quinquennat
vous avez sans doute tout essayé comme
l'a dit en son temps françois mitterrand
mais vous avez fait tout et son
contraire parce que vous n'avez ni cap
division merci